في الوس جورنال نقرا ان مواصفات النفق
الذي تحدث عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي تكشف عن
حجم استثمار حركه حماس في بناء شبكه
الانفاق الخاصه بها ومدى قله درايه
اسرائيل
بتفاصيلها يثير حجم النفق الذي تقول
اسرائيل انه قريب من قاعده عسكريه وفق
محللين الكثير من التساؤلات حول عدد
الانفاق الاخرى من نفس الحجم التي تمكنت
حماس من بنائها بالقرب من اسرائيل من دون
علم
جيشها كشفت صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت ان اي
اعلان عن تدمير حماس قريبا سيكون وهما
ومفصلا عن الواقع تلفت الصحيفه الى ان
الوضع في خانيونس مختلف واكثر تعقيدا عما
كان عليه الحال في شمال قطاع غزه وتعلق
بالقول ان فرق الجيش العامله هناك تعلم ان
وقتها محدود بينما تبرز مؤشرات هامه الى
ان قياده حماس لا تزال يسيطر على الكتائب
العامله في خانيونس فحماس وفق الصحيفه
اثبتت انها جيش لا نهايه له تنطلق مجله
التايم من الحديث عن توجه المسؤولين
الاوروبيين نحو الدعوه الى وقف اطلاق نار
مستدام في غزه وتغير لهجه الاداره
الامريكيه تجاه اسرائيل وتزايد التركيز
على الحرب الاسرائيليه ضد حماس ثم تختم
المجله بالقول استنادا الى خبراء ان
القضاء على ايديولوجيه حما
امر مستحيل حتى وان تمكنت اسرائيل من
القضاء على الحكومه في غزه بل سيترتب على
ذلك فراغ سيتعين ملئه ها ارتس قالت في
افتتاحيتها ان مقتل الرهائن حادث خطير
يتطلب استخلاص الدروس بشكل فوري وتغييرا
في النهج سواء فيما يتعلق باولويه صفقه
الرهائن او طبيعه القتال في قطاع غزه وعلى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تضع عوده الرهائن
على راس جدول لاعمالها وان تعمل على
التوصل الى اتفاق لاطلاق سراحهم وفي مقال
اخر من هارتس نقرا ان الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
نمى بوتيره ابطا مما كان متوقعا خلال
الربع الثالث من العام الجاري ما يعيد
خيار خفض سعر الفائده الى طاوله النقاش
جاء في المقال ان معدل النمو خلال العام
المقبل يتوقف على مدى طول الحرب في غزه في
المقال اشاره ايضا الى قلق متزايد لدى
صناع رار في اسرائيل بشان زياده الانفاق
الحكومي لتمويل الحرب وتعويض المتضررين من
هجمات السابع من اكتوبر تناول تقرير بالوا
شنطن بوست مخاطر توسع دائره انتشار المرض
في غزه واعتبره تهديدا جديدا يضاف الى
الدمار الذي لحق بالقطاع يستعرض التقرير
قائمه من الامراض ويقول انها تجد بيئه
مناسبه للانتشار في اكثر اجزاء غزه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وسط نقص حاد في الادويه
وانهيار نظام الرعايه الصحيه ويسجل
التقرير ان فئه الاطفال هي الاكثر تضررا
والاقل قدره على
المقاومه